all right happy strange
[Music]
Loop who's having a good time so far
today woo all right all right I will
admit this is my first strange Loop so
why not go out with a bang and get your
first strange Loop talk at the last one
right all right y'all um I'm very
excited to be here today
it's a topic that is near and dear to my
heart and we're going to be exploring it
but first off there's going to be a
couple of points here there's mild
audience participation I know I know I
know you're back in school again but I
think we can all do that
right all right that's what I like to
see this is going to be a fun talk y'all
let's have some fun today I'm here to
talk to you about open data's importance
in machine learning now when coming up
with this talk there's a lot of talks
ideas out there you can give but
alternatively I wanted to title this
talk how do we save the world from
robots and Tech
overlords yeah hell yeah I like to see
that let's get excited for saving the
world I think I can do one more better
right one better let's title this how do
we save our world from robots built by
Tech Overlord
words yeah let's give it up let's save
our world together everyone we're all on
this planet in this little blue dot in
the
sky now the reason I think it's really
important I'm a huge open data fan I'm a
huge open source fan I got my start in
Tech because of open data and open
source but I'm a journalist by trade I
went to school for journalism and art I
have a minor in gender studies too I'll
let you know when I use
that um but in all reality a little bit
more about myself so you know who
exactly I am just talking up here kind
of doing weird audience participation
things my name is Aaron male Staples I'm
a developer Advocate and developer
experience engineer I'm a stand-up
comedian on the side my work's been
featured in The New York Times Financial
Times and LA times for comedy I'm a
rescue dog parent that's right you're
going to see pictures of my dog later
it's part of being a rescue dog parent
hell yeah we don't dog
pictures oh and I'm looking for my next
job as a developer Advocate or developer
experience engineer so if you're hiring
hit me
up there's a QR code for that at the end
of my talk as well don't
worry now just a quick heads up we will
have time for some Q&A today
additionally everything in this slide
deck this presentation will be available
on my website immediately after this
talk some of it's already there don't
worry there's a QR code code at the end
you have to stick
around additionally I'm as what you
would describe is very
online that basically means I'm on every
single platform out there and I spend
way too much time and I justify it as
building relationships and work
AKA find me on this strange Loop slack
or find me on one of these multitude of
platforms and you know until that you
know career pigeon platform debuts I
guess I'm hanging out on the internet
now Shall We
Begin today's adventure I love you guys
this is a great audience um first off
we're going to talk about where we're at
now in the world of open data machine
learning and what's happening we're
going to talk about what exactly is open
data what does it
mean and then why do we even what does
it have to do with machine learning why
should we care what's the worst case
scenario after all how many of us have
just been like it's not that
bad and then what can we do to save the
world okay y'all
ready
woo so first off let's explore the
current state of machine learning and
see what exactly is out
there now machine learning has really
hit the Zeitgeist as of late we've seen
the New Yorker period in cartoons I'm
currently building robots on the side to
roast comedians in New York city um and
it's hit a lot of headlines my personal
Zeitgeist metric does my mother know
what machine learning
is fun fact I spent the last year
working in machine learning and my mom
does still has kind of maybe what an
idea of what I do she thinks I build
robots online for a job which is not
exactly
wrong but when we think of machine
learning and we think of a lot what's
out there right now we get the Doom
scrolling headlines do I do I have any
people working in machine learning here
just curious cool we got a few of you
welcome to the club it's a lot of fun um
there's a lot of scary Doom scrolly
headlines there's a lot of stuff that
you look online and you cry a little bit
but we're at a Crossroads the world of
machine learning the world of these
models and algorithms have become more
accessible than ever before and that's
pretty cool you would have told me 5
years ago I was working in machine
learning I would have looked at you like
you were a little bit on the Looney Bin
like not great there but what we're
doing at this Crossroads is thinking
about where we can have a lot of impact
could we really take a stand against
these Tech overlords right
now out of all the think pieces all the
headlines and all the articles that are
out there I think this article is one
that I really reference a lot when I
think about the current impact and the
concerns this article which was featured
in Scientific American
written by Dr Emily Ben M bender and
Alex Hannah earlier this year talked
about the real harm that Ai and machine
learning can use it also talked about
hey let's quit thinking about the hype
and the think pieces and actually focus
on
it so how exactly did we get here how
did we end up at this really interesting
Crossroads of open data machine learning
and you guys let me take the stage at
strange Loop now let's fast forward
let's go on a little trip through time
together first off let's fast Zoom back
in time it's
1949 the concept of machine learning was
just starting to really get the hang of
things we think about machine learning
by Donald Hub who came up with this idea
of like hey this is how neurons work I
think we can do something with computers
and by modeling off of what they've
learned a few years later the first term
and the first time that we saw machine
learning really come into play you used
together was first used by Arthur Samuel
of
IBM and this concept of machine learning
it wasn't the machine learning you know
of today we had understood how a game of
checkers work we weren't quite beating
humans yet or chess Champions at that
point but we knew that we could build
models that theoretically would play
checkers pretty cool in the 1970s we
made our next major jump that we like to
see in machine learning this is at the
point when there was so much data out
there that we could start to see more
data out there and use it to build
artificial neural networks so process so
much more data than the average human
could really cool in the 1990s we
developed this idea of boosting
algorithms what that means is we were
allowed to start taking machine learning
to the next level this gave us the
foundation and what's required to think
of things like computer vision so has
anybody used a backup camera or you know
a cool Snapchat filter yeah yeah y'all
have benefited from that work computer
vision is pretty freaking cool and now
by the 2000s we saw the basis of the
technologies that gave us Foundation
models that's what we think of when we
think of those generative AI models
things like you know our do our gpts our
diffusion models a lot of that
technology was first come up with in the
early
2000s so that bit of a timeline there
let's Flash Forward to now we're on the
precipice of robots building other
robots
wild we are now starting to see and
explore what it looks like when we build
models based off of data that is
generated by a model little bit
meta so now that we know what we're at
in the world of machine learning let's
explore the other half of the
equation who knows what open data
is we've got a few who has worked with
open data a few more who's you know who
has thinked their maintainer who has
probably managed an open data set
recently if you haven't offer them to
buy a beer they'd probably really
appreciate that and if your guys are
hanging out in the hallway don't be
stranger I promise I showered there's
some extra seats in here have some fun
um I'm going a flashboard we're going to
travel back through my own personal
history um this is me in grad school um
look at that naive person on the left
she probably still has an ID band
walking around that's her first day of
grad school nice selfie there Erin um
probably still using that ID card
carrying it around my hip to get into
the building um later on that's someone
who had never really worked with open
data and was intimidated by the world of
machine learning on the right that's
still me but that's someone who was
doing some research based on open data
in our public health system so at the
time I was working on a project in grad
school looking into Lyme disease
misinformation and a lot of the research
that we did came from the world of open
data and machine
learning I didn't think that I'd be
working in that a few years later after
this but it's pretty cool what can
happen when we open to a world of open
data so where did this world of open
data come from as
well um first off let's explore the
formative years of the internet in the
1960s these are actual notes from my
graduate school textbooks of how much
optimism people had on the internet in
the 1960s people were like hell yeah
internet's dope we're going to have a
lot of rules excitement going on um
guess what things happened and there are
scientific studies this is a lot from
thinking about the internet and how it's
built we don't have that same optimism
in the internet actually if anything
every single day that we exist on this
little blue glob Studies have shown that
there is less interest and less trust in
things on the internet than ever before
terrifying actually
but when thinking of open data this is
not a New Concept this is not
revolutionary the concept of open data
is actually just a few years earlier
than the world of machine
learning in 1942 researcher Robert King
Melton came up with this concept of open
data his
belief research should be available and
openly accessible to
everyone the world can only be a better
place when we all contribute to the
larger common pot of knowledge and we
give up our intellectual rights to allow
knowledge as a species and a society to
move
forward wouldn't that be cool if
everybody still thought that
today
yeah um to sum things up this is a great
shot if you want to get your screenshots
in and take a photo of this remember it
for later open data now is defined as a
philosophy and a practice requiring that
certain data be freely available to
everyone without restrictions from
copyright patents or other mechanisms of
control one thing that I want to put out
on this if I could like triple underline
freely available to everyone without
restrictions that would be where we'd
put some highlight underline there even
more so where does this open data come
from and I will put a disclaimer here
this is largely coming from a US Centric
lens so again there are a lot of global
projects we're going to look about it
from a us-centric lens and acknowledge
my bias
there on May 9th 2013 President Obama
signed an executive order it was
actually one of the first executive
orders of his administration period he
signed an executive order that made open
and machine readable data the new
default for government
information his intention open data can
increase
transparency it can increase trust and
public
accountability pretty cool we saw arise
in open data from Health Energy
climate
education Finance Public Safety and
Global development sectors this data was
then used and we hired teams of
maintainers and Builders to manage these
data sets as well as making them open
and accessible possible via API on the
public government
website well these are just some of the
organizations that are still doing it to
this day um personally I live in New
York I am a contributor and have
maintained been part of the people
who've hung out at New York City open
data week yeah thank you thank you um we
have also seen the Smithsonian has a
public open data set um the Department
of Education actually has some really
fun data sets if you ever want to look
at school districts and cry a little bit
about public education in the state of
America um Federal data strategy there's
a lot of really cool cancer and medical
research open data sets out there
there's a lot of organizations that are
having it out there but as much as we
absolutely love open data and we love to
see this does anybody know what happens
the long term with Government
funding yeah we can laugh a little bit
um this isn't really a priority
anymore the amount of open data that
exists and high quality open dat exists
has
decreased the priority and the public
accountability for open data is not
there actually so I'm an adjunct
instructor at NYU will bit a little bit
on the side we reference the New York
City public data set sometimes we have
to go back to 2012 to see the pretty
well laid out
examples this is no longer an initiative
that we really are prioritizing I think
that's a
problem so what the heck do these open
data sets have to do with machine
learning foreshadowing here this is when
you get to see a picture of my dog it's
pretty
cute first off for those of you who've
worked with data we know that data tells
a
story data lets us know how well our
school districts are performing traffic
on city streets or even helps us build
the model to create that cool Snapchat
filter with the dog ears and your tongue
out that's all built off of data good
stories
they have
context many times we need to add you
know where are people's faces aligned to
build that Snapchat filter what
buildings exist surr a city street why
are this
important machine learning at its core
is just a way to solve problems at
scale and without the right context can
we ever solve the right
problems is the traffic in New York City
going to be the same as the traffic in
Kansas
City do we have the same public
infrastructure in Europe as we do in the
United
States these are context problems I
would also argue without the right
context can we even solve these problems
at all or rather are we creating more
problems we've read the headlines we've
seen the ads when it's been going bad I
would argue because of the way that
machine learning models are built
sometimes we're making more
problems so let's break it down this is
a very very simplified example of what a
foundational model is trained off of the
tldr lots of data lots of things
happening all over the Internet we put
it in we train a model of on items that
are out there good bad and different for
those of you who aren't aware a
foundation model is a generative AI
model so think your chat GPT
your llama your Dolly stable diffusion
those type of models where you're
generating a thing of content needs to
be on ginormous data
sets problem is we don't really know
what data they were trained off of and
how so we're gonna we'll see an example
this is my dog Q very cute yeah claps
for
Q um I found out this morning he got in
trouble at daycare again so let's hope
that he doesn't get kicked out by the
end of this
conference um so Q if we were to train a
machine learning model about dogs based
off of my dog Q he's terrified of the
rain he's actually weirdly okay with
fireworks but thunderstorms
noo I probably have the only dog in the
world allergic to peanut
butter yeah I know oh no big deal um
he's big drama um we also are terrified
of squirrels
and the broom and the vacuum and the
glove so if we were to build let's theor
let's play out in our imaginary world I
am working at a large pet store company
and I want to be looking at machine
learning models predicting trends of
what people want to have in their dogs
and I train it off of my dog Q I love Q
he's not he's not a stereotypical
dog I officially just killed every
peanut butter flavored dog treat they
would no longer be out there as a dog
owner who has a dog allergic to peanut
butter do you know how many different
dog products have peanut products oil in
them that's like 70% of
them also I have also decided if we
trained this machine learning model
based on this
very Niche data set we would have no
toys that look like squirrels cuz that's
not not what he would
want now this is a very silly
light-hearted goofy example on a very
Niche data set of my goofy dog with one
data point and a bunch of statistics
about him but this can have real impact
so a lot of my work that I did in grad
school was on early sentiment analysis
and looking at comment sections and
online forums to determine if news media
was actually getting the response that
it did fun fact this was 20 right before
the election and so the comment section
online forums in political journalism
was not great um shout out to my
therapist um but while I like to make
light-hearted jokes about this joke in
retrospect we were able to do a lot of
this thanks to scraping Reddit and
Twitter well earlier this year we lost
some access to that and Reddit and
Twitter said no no no you don't get
access to our public Ally available data
even though it's in a public space and
Forum other places followed suit and
said we don't want machine readable or
scrapable
data now if you're working in machine
learning this is a bit of a problem data
is a really big thing and a NE like a
needed thing when you're looking at
models
but people weren't really a
fan additionally lobbying and public
dollars has actually impacted this
problem even more
fun fact earlier this year Congress was
found out that they were allowed to use
generative AI models pretty
cool open AI lobbied Congress and said
ah you can only use AI models if it's
our AI
model so there is a limit in our current
Congress that the only model that they
can use is chat GPT on the Pro Edition
to work on
policy personally I think that's a
little
concerning don't know about
you a lot of companies have started to
Lobby this problem and which leads us to
a little bit of a worst case
scenario what happens if a few people
start to make the rules for
many what happens when these models
start to impact our everyday
lives so we're not all doom and gloom
we're going to pull up from the Doom
scrolling I swear that's why we had a
dog pictures CU otherwise we'd spiral um
that being said let's start advocating
for some solutions I'm curious how many
people have worked with a publicly
available data
set wow almost everybody loved to see it
how many people have worked with the
IMDb data set at one point wow a lot of
us I don't worry me too me too I've
worked with the IMDb data set so one of
the problems that we're currently facing
in machine learning is that there's not
a really great variety of data sets out
there to learn off of and if we're all
learning off the same te 10 data
sets what problems might we
have so in order to build a better
future with machine learning here's what
I'm proposing and it's not just me these
are people who are building for the open
and better future of machine learning
overall first off couple places we need
to focus on our open data efforts a
standard file format many times that
means we need to have a open data set
the reason we've probably all used that
you know IMDb data set is it's pretty
widely available via API CSV I think
there's even a SQL database about it but
we need to have a standard file format
that we can all
use we love the metadata the reason that
IMD data set is super good it's got so
much Rich met metadata we know what
person What actors are in there we know
who's been involved and so on and so
forth we also have a knowledge of period
perios it's a $100 word for today and
consistency it's got clear time frames
when was it updated when was it
maintained and is it consistently
available and consistently regulated
everybody think a maintainer today these
are the people yeah give it up for the
maintainers never going to turn down an
Applause come on this is fun um and
lastly people have advocated for API
access can you call or access this data
very easily via an
API
important now we also see the five C's
of data integrity and this is from
O'Reilly but we're also seeing this a
lot in open data persons and also in in
a lot of data science initiatives right
now so the five seeds of dat data
Integrity
consent are you getting people's consent
to use the data do they know where it's
coming from and have they opted in
remember opt in not opt
out
Clarity do we know what this data is how
many times have we opened up a CSV or a
database and cried a little bit yeah
same same I currently have a very silly
side project I'm working on of pairing
with a friend who's a data scientist and
we're cataloging the Naked and Afraid
data set publicly in an openly open
source database um and we had to clean
up the consistency and Clarity of how is
it a City versus a state versus a
country of where people are competing in
this goofy reality TV show fun fact this
state was Georgia not Georgia the
country Georgia the
state
consistency are we consistently
maintaining this data set in ways that
is going to be maintained for the long
run is it consistently being updated
going back to our federal dollars did
the money run out and then people just
give up very real problems
control who has control of the data is
this someone who's a company that's
going to just go under and it's bye good
luck is this something that the data set
could be acquired by someone else who
has access to edit and modify that
data and lastly
consequences what long-term consequences
do this does this data have or could
have in the future future we need to be
thinking about these things from a
long-term perspective consequences means
that we need to be thinking about yes I
just gathered a bunch of people and I
use I get migraines there is a app out
there that collects data about
migraines does that app give you know
resources and they sell my data to a
pharmaceutical company and my price of
my migraine medication just went up a
bajillion
dollars that's a scary consequence even
though it's telling me the trends and
helping me predict when I'm going to get
a
migraine that's a pretty negative
consequence but don't be afraid there
are organizations out there that are
actively putting these practices into
action every single day so here's a few
of them and then I'll leave you with a
few tips of like where we can get
involved and what you can do to help
save the world but one of the
organizations I'm really excited about
um I am a sibling and a child of cancer
survivors so I love to say that the
European Federation for cancer images is
a very cool one that I've been watching
it is a Federated open project that is
actually set to release their first set
of research and data sets at the end of
this year what they're doing is they're
building an open library of images of
cancer so that we can build better
detection modules and help people get
and discover cancer faster we're
building off this open Collective
knowledge that's out there
and again I'm going to be biased in this
next one but it's near and dear to my
heart um New York City open data so that
we have an open data week in New York um
it's pretty fun I have been very
fortunate to be a volunteer for it and
have worked with it and helped students
get their into open data through
contributing with some of the grage
students that I work with um and it's a
government-driven Initiative for public
data but they also use data for fun so
they do cool art projects and
infrastructure projects real life
example of this being put into use is
there is a group here actually two
blocks from my house in New York City is
one of the most deadly intersections in
Brooklyn New York hit by cars people are
hit by cars there and it's terrifying
but they're using this open data set to
advocate for bike lanes and and
pedestrian safety which is super cool
like okay not super cool about people
getting hit by cars but super cool we're
using real life data for making a better
end of
solution so what now
if you leave nothing from this
conference or nothing from this talk
what I want you to do is thank your
maintainers understand that context is
very important and understand in order
to build the better machine learning
models and to have an ethical future of
machine learning it all comes down to
open data at its core we need more data
sets and more important ethically obtain
data sets in order to build a better
future with machine learning and this
can't be ran by the few it's going to
take the many so again thank your
maintainers give them some love and
lastly if you want to chat about this or
if you're looking for a developer
Advocate or you want to check my sources
there's a QR code there that'll point
you to a page on my website this talk
once it is updated and if you don't want
to follow that there's a nice little
link you can also reach me at aaron.
cool all my links are available at
aaron. bio hope to see you around but
again thank a maintainer check my
sources and let's have some fun have a
good
[Applause]
one so we're talking about open data as
a public good do you think we're
entirely dependent on government
initiatives uh to kind of generate a lot
of open data sets or is there a way that
we can make it profitable for companies
to actually engage Embrace open data
initiatives I love this question um
because I personally as much as like I
do think that like the federal
initiatives in the United States helped
and have been one of the biggest drivers
towards open data I really hope that
more companies can get involved and
there are companies out there that are
building in public in open source and
doing a lot of work um so I spoke at Pi
data earlier this year and a lot of
academic institutions that are backed by
company initiatives are currently doing
that so I'm blinking at the one on the
top of my head of course it's what
happens but I'm happy to send you some
more um additionally I also think that
there's a lot of community-driven
solutions that we can rely on um one of
the bias the projects that you know you
always happened is who funds the project
often unintentionally biases a project
so both government entities and
companies do have their own biases at
stake which is not a bad thing I think
it's just we just have to disclose that
um but I hope to see more independent
research and academic Scholars or even
just open source contributors to do so I
currently maintain a very quirky
collection of open data sets that are um
based on reality TV and pop culture so
hit me up and there are things that I've
either found and contributed to or
playing around with or exploring so I
hope more people do that thank you yeah
thank
you I guess I'm next um so I work at an
academic
Library University and um so we have we
have our own open data week that we have
uh in October and um so what would be
one piece of advice that you would give
Librarians who are interested in this
topic um absolutely love this question
as well um also thank a librarian if you
haven't because they save our lives and
make our lives better for so many
amazing reasons um yeah I'm like give it
up for librarians if you're still around
like cuz so much yeah that's what we
need to do
um one of the things that I really
appreciated about open data week in New
York is they actually really explored I
think so many times and even myself like
I came from a liberal arts background I
was scared to use open data at first and
I was like oh my goodness it's super
technical or it's super you know hard
and complex breaking it down and showing
that it doesn't always need to be a
technical skill actually I think a lot
of the things that we're missing in data
science and machine learning is the
context problem so even if you're
annotating a data set and putting it on
a read me if you are creating an art
piece on open data there was a really
cool exhibit um recently and it was
actually it was a couple years back now
but it was in the Nevada Museum of Art
and they took um temperatures and they
put it on like a cool chart that was
like blown with glass but it was based
on a publicly available data set about
climate change in Nevada and I was like
this is so cool but it's also very
pretty so challenging for people who
don't traditionally see themselves in
data science to get involved and get
involved in the way that I think is very
interesting and thinking it more of a
storytelling problem not so much as a
machine learning techie problem so be my
advice and I'm also happy to chat about
it if you want it more
because academics I got the nerd comes
with the glasses I'm a nerd at
heart so thank you thank
you opening data probably uh not not
very new problem and it was a lot of
experience with that uh and in many
cases opening data is kind of
dangerous uh thing to do so you can be
suit you could be masterer size uh with
all that stuff what are the patterns
developed so far to break that stigma to
close a
data yeah to break the stigma of closing
the data yeah I think this is a really
good problem I think it goes down to
consent so every time that you're
collecting a data point whether it's an
intentional they filled out a form and
said I opt in or if it's a passive data
collection meaning that you've been
tracking them on their site which
there's a whole other ethical discussion
we can get into there is what is the
consent that you've opted into the data
and what is the people whose data that
is what do they think of that and again
going back to the impact problem where
might we have impact issues so actually
um I used to volunteer there's a group
that I volunteered with it's a
factchecking group that would fact check
uh it was an election incident Response
Group and so it was a group that um
basically works with journalists and
newsrooms to track incidences of
violence and hate speech and amb bigotry
that happens during election periods and
we did have to close off some of our
data but the reason was is because
people were coming in who had bad
intentions and were damaging the data
set so we couldn't follow it but one of
the things we did is we created like an
onboarding process so it wasn't like no
you you're never getting the data ever
it was like Hey because unfortunately of
Bad actors we need to restrict some of
this data and make sure that it's safe
for everybody and is actually doing the
or intention that we need to get to
which is creating a better and a more
informed electoral public and keeping
people safe as they go to vote so that's
kind of what I would recommend is
thinking about it and the long-term
impact of it thank you thank
you hi there hi so certainly first
thanks for your talk was awesome slides
information great thank you um second
thing um we talked about some of the
data sets that you enjoy using you like
um um the NYC open data um my two
questions sorry um question one being
are there data sets that you've come
across that you saw and said oh Lord no
one should ever use this data and then
the second question is are there like
teams
or um groups that are kind of doing the
work of looking at open data sets and
providing that a level of analysis on
the data sets that are out there um so
those are the two questions one person
and then two open groups that are also
reviewing them yeah so first off on your
first question of a data set that I've
been like oh man we shouldn't be looking
at this one um one of the places that I
and it was actually shared in a among
friends that I used to work with a
machine a machine learning engineer I
used to work with shared this one and we
were like oh man um so password leaks
are a thing thing that happened someone
built a machine learning model with the
original intention of testing passwords
and security purposes but it's openly
accessible and available
of but it's based off of password leaks
so that's a little scary um to know that
that's out there um but it's definitely
one it's publicly available and it's
been used in academic research um so
that's one of the ones that initially
comes to mind there and as far group
groups that are maintaining and kind of
providing the context question um there
if you look into open science
initiatives we see a lot of this and
there's a big open science movement
right now and public data movement which
is kind of getting more people into that
and talk to those folks open data weeks
are kind of a common thing that are
starting to happen so check out those
places um also kaggle if you're into the
data science and machine learning World
they have a lot of really great
resources to getting started and a lot
of people will upload their data sets
there also there's there's a lot of
libraries if you just Google like like
for an example I wanted to build a
Beyonce data set for just silly Beyonce
yeah because why not it's Beyonce okay
come on like great um and someone has
done a data set of Beyonce best song
lyrics which is like a bajillion songs
long because it's
Beyonce um so kind of exploring with
that and if someone isn't maintaining it
this is a call to action be the person
to maintain it so like again in my goofy
example um I'm currently working with
someone who I've never met in person
across the internet a fellow twitch
streamer and we're building um Naked and
Afraid reality TV show data set and
maintain and doing weird things with it
so yeah do it take advantage of it have
some funol and if anybody wants to help
hack on some naked and afraid data in L
reality TV hit me up because it's pretty
fun thanks so much Aon and I think
that's the thing we're getting kicked
out for time but I'm happy to chat with
you afterwards thank
you